所以在过去的九年里，我一直在准备工作室工作
是洛杉矶和加利福尼亚南部的一个独立开发商
在过去的五年里，我一直是那里的主要引擎和图形程序员
差不多吧
以防你从这次谈话中看不出来
我喜欢谈论GPU和API
有时我就是不停地谈论他们
所以我也在我的博客上写了很多博客
危险区域
我在推特上
我在GitHub上也有开源项目
你可能在网上知道我是MJP
只是我名字的首字母
但不是很有创造力
所以我让你们都在这个房间里
这次演讲是关于什么的
所以很明显，我们将讨论GPU同步
但这是对他们的真正介绍
所以你知道你可能会看到
我们已经
你知道的
我们已经讨论了很多关于障碍和跨
你知道你知道很多过去的gdcs和cigraph
你知道
如果你对Gpus的工作原理没有真正深入的了解
你可能不知道到底发生了什么
你知道GPU同步正在发生
你可能会知道
你为什么要这么做
你知道得到正确的结果
你可能不知道引擎盖下到底发生了什么
当你喜欢的时候
比如说DirectX 12中的过渡屏障
然后你知道很多关于障碍的谈话
真正关注它如何影响你的表现
以及如何正确使用它们
为了让你知道更多的最佳性能从你的游戏
但你知道你可能没有真正直观的感觉
比如它到底如何影响性能
以及以何种方式
所以这次演讲的很大一部分是试图帮助你建立
就像一个关于正在发生的事情的非常粗略的心理模型
当您执行同步操作时
这样你就可以知道发生了什么
以及它将如何大致影响你的表现
所以你们知道你们中的任何一个人都熟悉DirectX 12或Vulcan
你知道这些新的显式API
你知道熊是一种东西
它们是一种烦人的东西
对呀
至少如果你来自一个你只是在工作的世界
你知道的
像DirectX 11和开放监狱
你其实不必
你知道的
手动发出屏障以获得正确的结果
但现在突然这些新的API你做对了
所以这实际上也很难做到
你必须知道，比如弄清楚这些在哪里
就像你所有的资源都有拐点
所以你可以发出这些手动屏障
你得这么做
否则你会得到
你知道吗
一种奇怪的不正确的结果，因硬件而异
你肯定注意到了
你知道吗
人们总是在GDC站起来谈论他们就像今天早些时候一样
当多米尼克在上面的时候
谈论你知道的障碍表演如何影响你的游戏
以及如何在RGP等工具中观察它
所以你又知道了
就像在这次谈话中
我希望你能从中得到什么
你能更好地理解
并有一个粗略的模型，你如何知道他们的表现会受到影响
当您执行同步操作时
所以在我们进入GPU的东西之前
你知道我们想给你一个快速的概述
以防你更熟悉
就像一个多核CPU编程感
所以嗯
你可能熟悉一种CPU屏障
这就是所谓的线程屏障
通常
它基本上是一个线程同步点
这意味着当你的代码中有一个障碍时
这意味着你所有的线程
当他们到达那个点时，他们的代码
他们会坐在那里，等待所有其他的线程到达那里
所以通常你可能会
您在用户模式下旋转重量
或者使用OS级原语
就像一个信号量来获取
基本上你就像是一种粗略的视觉隐喻
因为这是一个收费广场
但它就像一个真正破碎的收费广场和缓慢
每个人都会在那里永远等待
而不是你知道
穿过它
然后你可能也处理了记忆障碍
尤其是在内存模型较弱的处理器上工作时
就像手臂处理器
你使用的这些记忆障碍
他们会
它们都是为了确保你读写的正确顺序
特别是如何在运行在其他核心上的其他线程上观察它们
所以你可能想说像
好的
我想确保所有这些写都在你的代码中的障碍点之前完成
或者你知道某些读操作发生在屏障之后
所以你知道他们
这很自然
它们影响到最低水平
处理内存的CPU操作
但它们也会影响编译器的顺序
基本上，它会向编译器发出信号，说
好的
不要重新安排我的阅读和写作
因为这可能会扰乱其他线程上的工作方式
所以你在这个例子中的视觉隐喻就像一个狗门
都是关于分段的
读写操作发生的位置
所以你可能想把你的阅读放在屏障的一边
例如
所以你知道
就像这两种障碍之间的共同点是什么
你也是你的GPU屏障
这里的答案真的是
这一切都是关于依赖关系的
对呀
在你知道的地方
你可能有
就像一个核心上的一个核心，产生了一堆数据
然后在另一个核心上执行另一项任务，读取数据
这自然形成了一种依赖
对呀
你会说任务B取决于任务A
所以当你有这种依赖时会发生什么真的很重要
您必须确保数据具有正确的可见性
这基本上意味着当你的依赖任务，如任务B在本例中
要读取数据
你要确保它读取并得到正确的结果
对呀
你知道它希望
没有种族条件或现金问题或诸如此类的事情
所以你知道
当您在单线程世界中工作时
您通常不会以这种方式考虑数据依赖关系
但他们完全在那里
您可能喜欢像偏移量一样计算到数组中
然后索引到具有该偏移量的数组中
然后你有两个依赖的操作
但你不必去想
因为一般来说，你知道编译器和CPU就像
自然地处理这件事
你真的知道一种自然的方式
所以编译器实际上可以查看这些代码，并看到
哦
我可以确定依赖关系
并可能做任何它需要做的事情来使它正确地工作
而且总的来说你不需要任何喜欢
你知道如果需要一个屏障
编译器甚至可以自动为您输入
然后几乎所有的CPU都会给你预期的顺序
你知道依赖内存操作
只要它发生在一个核心上
你知道吗，一切都很正常
那样的话
基本上你知道这将是你的轻松模式
对呀
你知道你真的不必去想它
事情正常工作
这是你知道的
你所做的编程
自从你第一次学会写Hello World
当然你要去多线程世界
突然间一切都变得疯狂
现在你的问题是
你仍然有依赖关系
但现在它们跨越不同的线程和不同的核心
它不再容易处理
自动找出这些依赖关系在哪里
因为你知道你有任意数量的线程和核心
他们都可以访问他们想要的任何内存
所以在这一点上，你的CPU和电源机制开始崩溃
所以你知道CPU有很多优化
在他们的低水平上优化他们的记忆操作
所以你知道
比如说
它们每个核心存储可能有
缓冲区和缓存之类的
很多时候
这会导致在另一个线程上观察到的内存操作顺序不同
我真的是你知道的
想说的是
你知道的
一切都有点分崩离析，让你失望了
你在树林里迷路了，除了你的木剑什么也没有
在本例中是标准原子库中的内存屏障
你真的只能靠自己
所以你知道一个非常简单的情况，你可能有一个依赖关系，就像
你知道你在这里有一个任务
我从橱柜里拿出面包
你们的下一个任务是涂花生酱
在面包上
所以很自然，这是一个依赖
因为在你拿到面包之前，你不能涂上花生酱
这里的问题
如果我们在两个核心上排列
就像涂花生酱的任务在得到面包之前开始了
任务完成对了
所以你可以看到那里有一点重叠
哪个实际上是不好的
在依赖关系的情况下
因为这个重叠意味着你会有一个竞争条件
涂花生酱的地方
你可以尝试使用还没有准备好的结果吗
所以你所做的
你知道在这种情况下，标准的做法是
你会贴一个小屏障
对，然后呼，它现在移动了
我们没有重叠
耶
一切都正常工作
你得到正确的结果
所以我们将把这种概念扩展到其他更复杂的案例中
所以你知道现在回到GPU
对呀
这就是我们在这里要谈的
最重要的一点
你知道这里要说的是GPU不是串行机器
对呀
就像你知道这是你经常听到的
它当然有很多核心
但我们还是倾向于很多时候
想想用一种非常串行的方式与GPU交谈
就像你知道的画这个东西
画那个东西做那个
你知道，这实际上是一种欺骗，对吧
你甚至可以在这里
这是渲染狗的捕获
就像你所有的抽签操作都是按顺序进行的
所以它有一个非常连续的外观
事实上，这些调试程序实际上是你一步一步地观察到的
发生了什么事，好像他们是连环的
但在现实中，这不是真正发生的事情
所以现实比那更复杂
实际上有很多硬件和魔法在幕后进行
从这个串行命令序列中提取并行性
所以现在这里
这是一个
这是无线电图形探查器的定时捕获
你刚才看到多米尼克说的
他说了所有很酷的功能
这基本上显示了一个绘制调用的完整列表
它实际上显示了他们完成的开始和结束点
它们是
你知道的
有很多
通常像顶点着色器和像素着色器线程
一切都在那里发生
所以如果你如果你看看这个
大家可以看到
尤其是当我们的下巴较小的时候
他们实际上不像完成
就像顺序一样
它们到处都是重叠的
对呀
你有多个抽签呼叫同时在飞行中
在那里完成了一切
因为你知道，就像我说的，GPU是一台并行机器
如果我们把这看作是对窗口的选择
它以稍微不同的方式展示了一种非常相似的东西
这是在一个更大的GPU上拍摄的
这是在我的RTX 280上
它显示了更多的平局呼叫，都在飞行中
同时重叠
所以你可以看到你是如何知道的
这里有各种各样的重叠
它不是连续的
这将我引向下一点
也就是说GPU是线程怪物
对呀
这又是
应该是新闻
但重要的是要记住
当你谈论同步时
你知道的
如果你看，这是一张来自英伟达最新架构的图表
图灵架构显示了一个高级图
你知道RTX 280
如果你看看这些中的每一个
这里有一大堆叫做流式多处理器的小单元
如果我们放大
你可以看到还有这些小单位可以漂浮30英尺
两位浮点和三分二
这里有64个车道
在这些短信上
所以如果你把它乘以GPU上的短信数量
你会意识到只有一吨线程并行运行
同时在GPU上
所以因为这些东西线怪
对呀
如果你想让它继续喂食
基本上最好的方法是有很多重叠的任务
正在往那边走
你可以得到更好的并行性
你可以做得最好的时候
你知道没有依赖
或者在某些情况下，硬件实际上可以帮助您
的
典型的案例是
当像素着色器运行到呈现目标时
通常这里有一个硬件可以
即使着色器执行无序，所有重叠
他们实际上可以从着色器中获取输出
把它们放回原位
然后做内存操作
这样这些像素着色器的观察结果就会在API中显示出来
提交命令
这真的很酷
当然，你知道我们做这一切
因为就像我说的，重叠提高了性能
你知道我们知道这是一个不断被提起的问题
但你知道我会更深入地讨论
这到底能为您提高性能
通过一些简单的例子
所以既然我们有这个大的并行机器运行很多线程
这意味着我们需要在GPU上设置某种形式的线程屏障
对呀
这是为了确保一堆线程
在另一组线程再次启动之前，您知道已经完全完成了
所以你知道如果你在
你知道两个抽签电话或者两个调度之类的
那么你需要做的是你需要一些机制
基本上等待这整批线程
这将从罐子调度中产生
等待它们完全运行到完成
所以它有点类似于你可能有的
如果你
你知道的
如果你使用一种基于任务的作业系统，带有CPU任务时间表
对呀
通常你有某种机制可以说
嘿
我提交了一批工作，我想等他们都完成
所以这是一回事
除了在这种情况下，它是在GPU上
实际上有硬件可以为你做到这一点
你经常看到这叫做同花顺或排水沟
或者等待空闲
因为你在等待所有的工作
通过整个管道
所以除了线程屏障
你也需要现金障碍
这是GPU独有的东西
因为通常或历史上GPU上有很多小缓存
他们没有像一个很好的
类似分层缓存结构
就像你在CPU上可能有的那样
这正在改变
和最近的架构，他们实际上更倾向于统一的缓存结构
但从历史上看，所有这些都像小缓存一样
关于这些的一个问题是，它们实际上并不总是相互一致的
这与典型的CPU编程有很大的变化
通常您只希望缓存是连贯的
这样跨多个核心的数据就可以知道
获得正确的可见性
所以如果你看这里的图表
这是从一个有点旧的AMD GCN架构
这是在他们的织女星架构之前
在这一点上，他们有这些小的l one缓存
这里是颜色缓冲区和深度缓冲区
如果你注意到这里
那些L一个
他们不会经历那个大的L 2在那里，他们会直接进入记忆，对吗
所以这可能是个问题
因此，如果您想象您知道您正在向呈现目标写入
它会经过颜色缓冲器
但是如果您想从呈现目标中读取
纹理单元l 1穿过l 2
所以我两个可能不得不无效
并且颜色缓冲区l可以被刷新到主存
以确保呈现目标数据具有适当的可见性
所以这是另一件可能发生的事情，因为屏障
当然还有
就像
你知道的
多米尼克之前说过
这对批量处理障碍总是很重要的
因为你知道
如果你要刷新你的缓存
一次做总比连续做八次好
无缘无故
然后是第三种障碍，你可能称之为压缩
或者是前面提到的布局障碍
但是你有很多常见的GPU
现在他们有了一个内置的硬件，可以进行无损压缩
这些主要是为了减少写入所需的带宽
渲染目标纹理
你可以在图中看到英伟达展示了他们的Delta彩色压缩技术
AMD也有自己的Delta颜色压缩形式
这是为了在你有这样的情况下节省带宽
通常是呈现目标的某个平铺或区域内的相同颜色或值
所以当你有一个压缩格式的纹理时
或者深度缓冲区
甚至你可能要给这个减压
可能取决于硬件，以便将其读取为纹理
所以如果你有一个障碍，从写状态变成读状态
你可能需要那种减压手术
发生也是可能的
可能需要进行某种减压或完全禁用压缩
如果你要写到那个纹理，以便访问你
因为那不是
可能不是通过渲染目标速率所通过的相同硬件
所以如果我们把这个带回到d 3 d 12
你知道的
如果你有经验的话
你会知道他们实际上并不在这种低水平上工作，对吧
您不会发出缓存屏障或线程屏障
相反，它们在一种更高的层次和抽象上工作
这是有道理的，因为它是一个API，旨在与许多不同的硬件对话
所以把这一切都泄露出去是没有意义的
像硬件特定的细节到API
所以取而代之的是，它与这种资源状态抽象一起工作
对呀
主要是说像
不管是你知道
资源可以被特定类型的管道阶段读取
或可由另一个管道阶段写入
你真正描述的是资源和可见性
从可见性数据
驱动程序可以从不同的转换中推断出隐式依赖关系
还可以推断您的布局和压缩操作
可能需要的东西来克服你指定的障碍
然后火神是它的火神模拟器
或
它只是比你在
三十二
但你仍然有一个更高级别的抽象
你只需要提供一点额外的信息
比如你必须更具体地说明CPU的生产和消费阶段
以及它是否处于读写状态
还有一些手动指定纹理布局的选项
但又一次
这两个都是关于抽象出GPU的细节，对吧
但尽管如此，你还是有点
你知道的
因为你是手动发出屏障的
很多时候你还在驾驶座上
就这些不同的操作正在发生的事情而言
你只是经历了一点抽象
所以结果是
因为你是手动发出屏障的
您将能够过度同步、刷新或解压
所以你必须非常小心如何使用你的障碍
好消息是你知道
AMD的Radion图形探查器实际上会向你展示发生了什么
当你发出屏障时
就它而言，它会向你展示
正在发生什么线程同步
哪个着色器阶段是
它会告诉你哪个缓存是
它在冲洗和失效
它也向你展示了屏障的来源
因为在某些情况下
你知道大多数时候你实际上是在明确地发出一个障碍
但在某些情况下，其他API调用可能会应用屏障
然后选择窗口有一个非常棒的功能
当你捕获时
它可以向您显示这些警告
告诉你什么时候你没有批量你的障碍
说
哦嘿
你有连续的呼叫资源屏障
也就是说，嘿，这是你的
你应该把这些放进一个电话里
将它们批量化的资源障碍
那么D 3 D 11怎么样
对呀
你知道就像我们之前说的
你真的不用担心这些东西
带屏障和同步
原因是实际上你知道障碍实际上是存在的
他们只是躲着你对吧
它们都是由司机处理的
驱动程序主要是通过自动为您跟踪依赖项来做到这一点的
幕后
它有点像一个大的运行时编译器
它在分析你所有的D三个D命令
您提交的框架
然后说
哦这里
以下是依赖关系
我需要在深度缓冲区上自动转换
所以再一次
这就像轻松模式
它省去了你思考这个的工作
这里最大的问题是，这是大量的CPU工作
司机做得对
它有一个分析
所有的东西
找出障碍
你知道的
只是他们通常通过这些类似驱动程序线程来做到这一点
在你的其他核心上运行
所以你知道那里有一吨的头顶
然后是另一个很大的缺点
也就是说，做这种自动依赖关系分析是
本质上真的很难使用多线程命令提交
这是因为你知道依赖
你知道你可能会把你的框架分成五部分
并跨多个线程执行这些操作
但是您的依赖关系可能跨越框架的这些不同部分
所以这表明司机必须
你知道的
序列化并将不同的并行提交放在一个大框架中
提交清单
为了找出依赖关系并为您插入障碍
然后最后，因为我们是它有一个
你知道驱动程序必须知道你的依赖关系并跟踪它们
这也意味着有某种你知道的
可见CPU
你知道API驱动的资源绑定
就像
你知道吗
这是某种明确的
就像嘿
将此纹理绑定到着色器阶段的插槽
所以这基本上排除了较新的爱好者
更牛逼
你知道我们可以在DirectX中做的无垃圾箱模型
十二和火神
所以是的
你知道的
这三件事基本上都不符合
DirectX 12和Vulcan
都是关于
你知道的
以尽可能低的CPU开销启用
并允许您提交多线程命令缓冲区
也使这些新的幻想
我买的资源绑定模型较少
所以现在我喜欢
再深入一点，具体讨论线程同步部分
我想有点
你知道的
我想这个会有帮助
而不是像看一个真正的GPU
这是非常复杂的，实际上看一个更简化的GPU
你知道很多类似的
Gpus如何进行线程同步的基本特征
但它有点脱光了
这样您就可以在这样的演示文稿中更容易地理解它
所以我给你介绍了
MJP
三千
它是由你设计的
真的嗯
这个宝贝有16个着色器核心
你可以看到上面贴着标签
那是很大的计算能力
它的左边有一些记忆
你会看到有一个命令处理器
它基本上一次处理一个命令
然后它就会用
基本上
那些命令
将用于将一堆正在运行的线程存放到线程队列中
因此，命令处理器和线程键一起形成了我们通常所说的
像一个前端
因为这些会进入着色器核心
会看到沉重的负担
然后在左上角有当前的周期计数
基本上你接下来要做的
就像过了多少时间
当我在这里浏览一些例子时
然后广义地说
你知道左边的命令处理器是你知道的
我会打电话给行动的大脑
这家伙将能够处理不同的命令
它主要负责调度
并找出哪些工作应该实际运行
同时着色器核心就是我所说的肌肉
因为这些家伙在做所有的重物
他们不聪明
他们不会
他们只是做他们被告知，他们只是运行事情
但他们实际上在做所有的工作和一些限制，与之相比
就像现实世界的GPU
我们只是要做一个计算
着色器分派
所以尽管我叫它GPU
我们实际上不会做任何图形
但这大大简化了事情
所以我们不必包括
就像光栅化器和所有不同的渲染阶段
就像我说的
只有16个着色器核心
这比你在典型的桌面上看到的要少得多
GPU或控制台
这里没有SIMD
所以你知道
大多数GPU将利用SID来大幅增加吞吐量
但这家伙身上没有SIMD
16个着色器核心可以被认为是完全独立的
这意味着他们每个人都可以运行自己不同的着色器程序
如有需要
也没有线程循环
这是你通常在Gpus上看到的
每种着色器核心都可以运行一点
然后切换到另一个线程
它通常会这样做，试图隐藏长内存访问的延迟
最后这里没有缓存
因为这也会简化事情
我不想
下一部分我们不讨论缓存屏障
我们将深入研究线程同步
让我们在MJP三千上运行一个简单的示例
所以说
假设我们只发送32个线程
每一个线程都将写入一个内存元素
它会
这些线程中的每一个都会说它需要大约100个循环才能完成
所以如果我们通过这个
我们开始
我们已经得到了调度
它有三根两根线
一旦它被命令处理器处理
我们将把三个T线程存放到线程队列中
我们现在坐在那里
然后当线程队列中有线程时
着色器核心会抽出一些线程来实际执行
所以现在我们有16个线程
都在着色器核心上执行
然后剩下16个线程和线程队列
所以这些就像
我说
这个特殊的着色器程序需要大约100个循环才能完成
所以如果我们向前跳一百个循环
所有的线都完成了
他们把结果写在右边的记忆中
而现在
线程队列中剩下的16个线程可以跳上着色器核心
轮到他们了
所以他们还需要一百个循环
然后他们会把结果写到右边的记忆中
所以所有的事情都花了200个循环好吧
所以让我们尝试一个带有一些同步的实际示例
因为这就是我们在这里谈论的
假设我们收到两份急件
现在我们要有一个调度
它将被涂成红色
然后我们会有颜色和绿色的调度B
我们说调度B依赖于调度A
基本上调度B将读取调度A的结果
正因为如此，我们不能有任何重叠对吧
因为我们想避免比赛条件
所以我们将引入一个新的命令
我们称之为同花顺
这个刷新命令基本上会导致命令处理器旋转
并等待着色器核心中的线程队列完全为空
它不会处理任何进一步的命令
直到基本上整个当前所有的线程和飞行运行完成
所以让我们试试
所以我们将从调度A开始
我们得到了两个四个线程的调度A
我们要进入线程队列
然后有16个线程最终会出现在着色器核心上
线程队列中还有八个线程
所以我们跳了一百个循环后
那一批就完成了
现在还有八个线程要调度
在着色器核心上运行的
如果我们看看命令处理器
你会看到它在同花顺上
所以它基本上要等待剩下的八个线程
让他们的方式
你知道在它进入分派B之前实际上完全完成
正因为如此，没有重叠
你知道调度B没有线程同时发生
但这也意味着我们一半的核心闲置在那里
所以我们基本上有50%的利用率
所以如果我们再跳一百个循环
那一批八个线程就完成了，把内存清除掉
现在命令处理器可以从它的刷新中继续前进
并开始处理分派B，它有另外两个四个线程
他们会进入线程队列
最后到着色器核心
一次处理16个线程
那需要一百个循环
然后在三百循环
我们从调度B得到了剩下的八个线程
现在在着色器核心上
这部分我们又得到了50%的利用率
最后，整个事情在400循环完成
让我们看看我们做得怎么样
所以冲水效果很好
它通过防止调度的重叠给了我们正确的结果
和很酷的调度B
这就是我们想要的
但不利的一面是
核心在200个循环中基本上有50%空闲
在整个四百循环中
有点
你知道的
我们在这里叫一个框架
这意味着我们得到了75%的总利用率
整个过程花了400个循环如果你仔细想想
我们里面没有屏障
我们一直都有百分之百的利用率
那需要三百个循环
所以我们花了很多钱在那里设置屏障
所以他们引导我们思考好吧
那么我们如何
你知道的
有一个心智模型
一个屏障的成本是多少
有一件事要记住，当你这样做的时候，
屏障成本基本上与利用率的下降有关
你从插入屏障中得到的
对呀
所以它造成的闲置核心的数量基本上是你的
你的屏障成本
至少在线程执行方面
不考虑缓存之类的东西
然后如果你把它翻过来
我们也可以猜测移除屏障的收益
大致相对于空闲着色器核心的百分比
从一开始就有障碍
所以闲置的核心越多
你更有潜力通过消除障碍来加快速度
或者以某种不必要的方式优化
然后呢
这也使我们得出结论，拥有更大的调度通常对
因为有更高的利用率
因为你会有更多的线程
只是保持着色器核心饱和
而如果您有较小的分派和较长的运行线程
这些会给你很高的冲水成本
因为如果你有一个很长的线程，这使得它更有可能
你是
你只会让命令处理器坐在那里等着刷新
利用率不到100%
所以记住这一点也很重要
所以当你做熊的时候
你知道的
过渡或管道屏障在D 3 12或Vulcan那里
通常大多数常见的硬件都会导致这种类似全局刷新的操作
您通常可以期待至少每个阶段的线程齐平
无论何时发布过渡
或者一对绘图或一对调度之间的管道屏障
所以通常你会有这种东西
命令处理器所在并等待的位置
对于一整组线程完全完成
你会因此在那里有一段时间的空闲时间
然后对于
如果你做无人机屏障，在D 3 D 12中可用
具有类似的含义
因为这意味着您希望将数据写入
从A到无人机
从调度器绘图中获取，以便对任何后续调度或绘图可见
所以你真的应该试着把你的非依赖绘图和分派分组
所以如果你有东西不是
你知道的
没有依赖关系
如果你能把它们和其他的放在一起，那就太好了
你知道事情不是
这不取决于你们之间的障碍
这给了你一种更多的线程来保持事情的占用
并可能提高您的利用率
当然你也要记住
我在这里说的更多的是
你知道的
当前现有GPU的种类
你会看到的
就像市场上的用户一样
或者现在有的
在未来
事情可能会完全不同
在硬件中可能有更细粒度的同步操作
我更多的是谈论目前可用的东西
所以记住这一点好吗
所以让我们试试另一个例子
这次我们要按我说的去做
我们将尝试与前面的示例重叠一些非依赖的工作
试图回收一些利用
所以我们将从前面的示例开始
在那里我们有依赖于
或者对不起
分派B依赖于分派A
然后我们会在混合中加入另一个调度
我们称之为蓝色C的调度
这家伙不会依赖他们中的任何一个
所以我们要试着把它们扔进去
回收我们的一些闲置核心
所以是的
就像我说的，我们要努力恢复一些表现
希望你知道
提高我们的使用率
所以我们就从
所以我们得到了这一批a
我们又得到了
这里有两个四根线
命令处理器将首先处理
它会得到那些
来自程序A的第一批16个线程
我们会在着色器核心上做出来
我们从编程和线程队列中又得到了八个线程
然后命令处理器已经处理了一个分派C
所以我们从调度C得到了八个线程
线程队列也在等待去
如果我们跳到一百个循环后
第一批线程分派完成
在这一点上，我们得到了程序A中剩下的八个线程
但是调度C的线程
能够偷偷溜进去，把剩下的核心
让他们忙得不可开交
而不是让他们闲着
就像我们上次
现在同花顺也要等待所有这些工作完成
这还需要一百个循环
然后调度B可以开始工作
把它的线插在核心里
所以这批16个需要100个循环
然后再循环一百个循环
最后八个线程最终完成并将结果写入内存
所以整个过程花了大约四百个周期一切都完成了
那我们这次怎么办
你可能会注意到我们基本上有相同的潜伏期
对于a加分派b从分派a开始
所以当调度B完全完成时
它花了同样多的时间
也就是四百个循环
不过，好的是
我们基本上免费得到了这批C对吧
我们只是偷偷把它放进去
它占用了那些闲置的核心，并完成了
我们实际上并没有增加总的运行时间
所以我们的整体吞吐量增加了
因为我们在同样的时间里做了更多的事情
如果你仔细想想
如果我们按顺序这样做
在哪里
如果我们做一个加B加C，中间有屏障
那需要500个循环
所以我们这样做基本上节省了一百个循环
我们的总利用率从75%上升到87%
百分之五
所以这很酷
我们得到了
你知道我们从硬件上得到了更多
基本上，我们可以从这个例子中得出什么见解，在前面的例子中
对呀
如果我们喜欢
你知道你摘下眼镜
斜视一点
你会想好吧
GPU
它和CPU没有什么不同
如果我
你知道把它想象成一个CPU
对呀
您可以考虑提交给GPU的每个命令
就像在CPU上执行的一条指令一样
那样的话
那么重叠有点类似于指令级并行
这是你得到的东西
很多现代处理器
在那里你会得到多个不同的指令，这些指令实际上是并行处理的
尽管它们是按顺序发行的
这里的一个问题是，这基本上是明确的
对呀
你知道的
我们必须明确地安排事情，以这样的方式安排我们的同花顺
这样我们就得到了重叠
所以在某些方面，它有点类似于一些更疯狂的
很长的指令字架构也有
那样的话
编译器主要负责识别依赖项并找出非依赖项的位置
依赖操作可能会潜入
通常就像那种SIMD
比如硬件
你知道吗，在我展示的最后一个例子中，你说我锻炼得很好
你知道我们有一个调度C，插槽不完美
但你可能很容易想象一个案例
在那里，这实际上不会很好地解决
对呀
你知道如果这批C花了更长时间
在这种情况下，我们要说好吧
如果这批C需要400个循环呢
这次真的有点把事情搞砸了
所以让我们看看这实际上是如何动摇的
所以我们将从调度A重新开始
我们会得到第一批派遣和着色器核心
如果我们跳到200个循环后
快进一点
我们看到
哦不
这是怎么回事
命令处理器正在等待刷新
所以它在等待一切通过着色器核心
但由于调度C真的很慢
这次需要四百个循环
它还有点坐在那里
停在核心上
所以你知道当我们现在
等待调度C最终完成
在我们继续调度B之前
在整个时间里，我们只有50%的利用率
我们一半的核心仍然闲置
所以我们不能最终进入调度B
直到循环五百
然后现在我们可以像往常一样进行了
在着色器核心上获得前16个线程
一百个循环后就是剩下的八个循环
然后整个事情结束了这个循环700
一切都在记忆中
所以是的
那里发生了什么
就是不太顺利
所以我们有四百个循环
我们只有50%的利用率
我们一半的核心闲置着
所以水滴是总利用率
整个序列下降到71.4%
这是相当糟糕的
所以我们试着
你知道吗
把东西偷偷放进去重叠起来
但相反，我们只是让事情变得更糟
这里识别它的真正问题是
我们只有一个前端
这意味着我们只有一个命令处理器
我们有一个命令队列
所以
这将我们所有的刷新变成全局刷新或同步
这是一个相当生硬的工具来同步事情
每次我们要同花顺的时候
命令处理器只会坐在那里等待
无法继续做其他事情
所以在这种情况下
你知道我们真的只是想让B在调度A上同步
但它最终也在调度C上同步
因为工作方式
所以很糟糕
然后你知道
重新安排
或者你知道你可能会把事情分开
帮一点忙
但它是一个
你知道这不会完全解决问题
取决于所有可能的配置
对呀
因为你不一定
总是知道任何分派线程需要多长时间
或者你知道事情将如何在不同的硬件上扩展
不同的分辨率之类的东西
所以如果你知道
如果一个前端、一个命令处理器或问题
然后你可能会想
好的
怎么一个不是两个
让我们在那里再扔一个
那我们就可以同时做两件事了
这并不像听起来那么疯狂
所以你知道
MJP工业公司的工程师
他们收到了你的反馈
他们接受了这个想法
我说
所有的权利
我们要把第二个前端塞进去
它有自己的命令处理器和自己的线程队列
一旦他们这样做了
他们意识到他们搞砸了，他们用完了晶体管预算
他们实际上不能在那里贴更多的着色器核心
所以他们说
哦不
我们被我们所拥有的困住了
我们还是十六岁
但是嘿
至少我们有这两个前端
所以也许这会有帮助
所以你知道
看着这个
这台机器的新野兽
所以我们看到
那里有两个前端
还有两个线程线索来输入我们的着色器核心
这里的关键是
现在它基本上使我们有两个独立的命令流
对呀
所以如果我们有两个不同步的命令流
它们可能只是在命令流中进行同步
这就是我们现在能对这家伙进行的调查
你又知道了
独立真的是这里要关注的关键词
就像我说的，我们仍然只有16个着色器核心
所以我们的最大吞吐量实际上并没有增加
对MJP三千
所以如果我们要
你知道的
如果我们达到100%的利用率
我们真的不能打败它
然后我们要用一个非常简单的
就像先到先得
服务于解决两个线程线索之间冲突的系统
所以基本上任何线程队列首先得到线程
我们会得到着色器的核心
如果他们同时到达那里
着色器核心会在两个线程线索之间均匀地分裂
所以让我们尝试一个简单的例子
所有的权利
所以假设现在我们有一个调度
它有六十八根线
每一个都需要一百个循环才能完成
然后我们得到了这批B
这是一种不理想的情况
这只有八个线程
它需要四百个循环
所以它自己不能饱和16个着色器核心
我们得到的b依赖于
所以他们之间会有同花顺
现在假设我们也得到了这批C
它有八十个线
每一个都需要一百个循环才能完成
然后分派D，这是相同的80个线程
一百个循环完成
d依赖于c的地方
所以这给了我们两个独立的命令流
很酷的
这就是我们想在GPU上给我们的双命令处理器提供的东西
所以我们要试试
我们将把它们作为两个不同的命令流提交，看看情况如何
所以我们从零周期开始
我们将提交第一个命令流
使用分派A到顶部命令处理器
然后你知道如果我们跳到50个循环后
我们可以看到着色器核心已经在线程上工作了
从发送a
在这一点上
我们将把第二个命令流提交给第二个命令处理器
因此，由于着色器核心已经与调度A绑定
调度C将有80个线程
它将被存放在线程队列中
他们会在那里等着，直到有什么东西打开
所以我们跳起来骑一百
现在第一批派遣
线程已经完成并将结果写入内存
现在着色器核心都是免费的
所以他们只是要
因为有线程和线程线索
他们只是要均匀地从他们身上拉出来
所以我们现在有
我们有一半的着色器核心被用于调度
一个线程和一半的核心被用于这一批
他们分享得很好
然后如果我们跳得更晚，循环600
我们现在可以看到
派遣A基本上正在逐步结束
所以在这一点上它只剩下四个线程了
所以通常如果我们在调度A上同步
我们没有另一个命令处理器
我们这里只有2.5%的利用率
但是因为我们有另一个线程队列
有一大堆线程在等着
嗯
我们现在可以发送
你可以增长并占用四分之三的着色器核心
我们可以保持百分之百的利用率
很酷的
我们会继续把事情做完
然后我们又跳了一百个循环
你知道吗
使用所有着色器核心分派C
现在他们有点在翻腾
分派B已经进入线程立方体
因为第一个顶部命令处理器完成了它的刷新
然后如果我们再跳一百个循环
现在我们有了这批B是
现在它的线程已经在着色器的核心上
就像我之前说的它只有八个所以它自己
它将无法饱和我们所有的16个着色器核心
但由于这批C还在继续
它可以利用剩下的一个核心
我们可以保持高利用率
它的周期是九百调度西正在结束
它只剩下四根线了
所以我们得到了75%的利用率
你知道这不是很好
但还是很不错的
一旦这个循环结束，一千
现在终于轮到派遣D了
你知道刷新在第二个命令处理器上完成
所以现在
分派B中的线程可以进入线程队列
并输出到着色器核心
他们基本上会和一个调度B分享它
一段时间，直到结束
然后在1200年左右，最后调度B完全完成
所以现在分派D只是可以自由地控制所有的着色器核心
我会一直用它们
直到我们循环1600
当一切都完成时
一切都在记忆中
我们就结束了
哦
那是很多
所以耶
两个前端也有帮助
我会说是的
它完全做到了
我们做得很好
我们得到了98%的利用率
这比我们以前的一些例子要高得多
你知道我们甚至没有增加我们的核心权利
我们这里的吞吐量越来越大
这真的很酷
所以基本上我们这里得到的是较低的总数
你知道的
的总执行时间
完成a加b加c加d比我们想象的要低
如果我们提交这些
这些都是在一个命令处理器上顺序进行的
很酷的
所以第二个命令处理器帮助我们获得了更高的吞吐量
基本上给了我们更低的总执行时间
但一个缺点是，我们确实有更高的延迟
如果你只看A加B或C加D
因为那些家伙在里面分享着色器核心
他们花了更长的时间
如果您只有一次提交给一个命令处理器
但如果你在乎
你知道
整体优化一切
这是件好事对吧
我们有点
你知道
有点像是在想
您希望有一个较低的总帧时间
即使做一个手术需要更长的时间
我想是O或类似的东西
然后是一个真正的GPU
可能会更好
它更复杂
很明显，因为就像我说的
在缓存和内存方面有更多的事情要做
你在早些时候的谈话中
但是你知道在真正的GPU上，你可能会在内存访问上出现线程停滞
然后发生了什么，就像我说的，他们得到了
他们会做线程循环
所以如果你有多余的
你知道来自其他命令处理器的工作
这可能会为着色器核心提供更多的线程来切换
很酷的
然后他们可以躲起来
等着瞧吧
你还得到了
你会在真正的Gpus上有空闲时间
由刷新这些缓存引起的
那需要时间
在启动新线程之前，命令处理器将坐在那里等待
所以如果一个命令处理器坐在那里等待缓存刷新
那么这是一个很好的机会，让另一个命令处理器投入一些工作
并使用着色器核心
然后你也有一种自然的
您的任务通常不使用着色器核心
非常正确
你知道你有一个案子
唯一的光栅化
你所做的一切
你知道的
像Z预通行证或阴影地图
使这些家伙大多只使用固定的功能单元进行光栅化
和用于深度写入缓冲区
所以如果他们不使用着色器核心
那是个做其他工作的好机会
你知道的
计算可以在着色器核心空闲时实际使用它们的工作
然后你有一些其他的情况
就像某些形式的行为
比如试图在芯片上保留镶嵌或几何着色器
而不是拼写它们
内存可以读取到这些自然的串行序列化点
在你不能不能的地方
这个词不能扩展到许多不同的着色器核心
所以这是另一个案例
在那里有一些额外的计算工作可能会很好
从另一个命令处理器扔进去
然后最后还有
你知道的
Gpus上通常固定的功能DMA单元
知道那些家伙根本不用着色器核心
所以如果命令处理器正在等待其中一个完成
这也是一个很好的时期，可能会有闲置的着色器核心
如果我们再一次用CPU的术语来考虑这个问题
把它和那里联系起来
嗯
有这种你知道的
多前端概念
和你得到的大致相似
具有同时多线程
这是CPU上的一个常见特性
现在你可能会在英特尔处理器上看到它被称为超线程
这种你知道什么
这个设置是做什么的
它基本上是试图交织两个不同的指令流
通常你知道两个不同的线程
你就会知道你必须
他们将共享实际的执行资源，实际上你知道
执行内存操作的指令
或者你知道做算术
这里的目标基本上是尝试
CPU
将尝试从我的缓存错过中减少停顿的空闲时间
通过切换到另一个线程
所以这真的有点像我们的目标，有两个命令处理器
GPU上的处理器
基本上你是想喜欢
你知道的
把你的
或者利用空闲时间从一个非
依赖命令流
所以我们要把它看成一个现实世界的例子
现在你可能会在一个真正的典型游戏引擎中看到
这张图显示得像一个
你知道的
典型后处理堆栈
就在你可能有一个
你可能会做一个主传球
这就像向HDR渲染目标的前向渲染
这将输入两个不同的后处理操作
尽管这是两个不同的操作
它们实际上由许多子步骤组成
所以开花是很常见的
你知道吗，你通常会做一些事情，比如缩小几次
做几个可分离的高斯咆哮
景深是另一件通常有的事情
被分解成一堆台阶
通常你会做一些类似
你知道计算深度值的混乱圈
然后可能会为了性能而缩小规模
然后做一个花束形状的聚集图案
所以你知道
这是两种不同的后处理操作
你知道它们彼此之间有依赖关系
但他们实际上是独立的
你知道彼此就像总的操作
对呀
水华基本上与这里的景深无关
所以这看起来是一个很好的机会
你知道吗
将这些移动到两个不同的命令处理器
所以我们这样做，像这样重新排列
所以这就是我们可能喜欢的
在
你知道的
Mjp四千
你可能会有所有这些
你知道你有这些不同的操作
他们确实需要一个命令处理器
局部同花顺
或者你知道我们也可以称之为
你知道，就像Q本地屏障
对呀
所以这里的这些家伙
这些基本上是在单个命令流中解决依赖关系
然后当我们也真的需要这样做的时候
我们需要某种交叉立方体屏障
因为我们得确保
我们不在第二个命令处理器上启动字段进程
直到主道完成
所以我们也需要这种同步
这实际上你很了解地图，喜欢你在里面的东西
比如DX12和火神
所以你知道直接x 12
您的应用程序将减少记录和提交命令
然后您将使用这些栅栏对象来同步它们
当他们提交时
发生的事情是
你知道的
当您将命令列表提交到DX12中的命令队列对象时
在引擎盖下
操作系统基本上有一个GPU调度器
GPU调度程序将收到您提交的文件
我会说嘿
我现在要计划在可用的命令处理器或硬件队列上运行
在GPU本身上
这些都出现在Windows驱动程序堆栈使用的术语中
就是
他们会调用这些GPU硬件队列中的每一个
发动机要么像
采取了一种直接的形式
它可以做所有的图形操作和计算操作
就像一个计算引擎
我们只能做计算调度
或者只能做复制的复制引擎
通常通过DMA
还有第四种
它是一个视频引擎
你通常不与DX12交互
但这确实像视频编码和解码操作
所以基本上你知道你有这些引擎暴露在调度程序中
您提交您的命令列表
然后他们会在发动机上运行
它通常表示命令缓冲区的一种硬件队列
然后然后是的
通常在硬件的另一端
你有某种命令处理器，实际上你知道
执行你的命令，做你的工作
所以如果我们拿前面的水华和景深的例子
现在我们把它映射到
就像DX十二种语言
我们把这样的东西弄对了
所以我们现在有
我们有一个直接命令队列和一个计算命令队列
所以我们将在我们的直接队列中
我们会做我们的主要通道
因为那都是图形的东西
这将是一个图形命令列表
我们会有另一个命令我们用直接键运行
让我们绽放
最后，音调映射是他自己单独的命令
同时
我们将把景深映射到计算命令列表
所以这些都是派遣
对，因为电脑可爱只能做电脑操作
你可以在那里看到
紫色盒子里有这些
有一个
你知道一个B
这表明这些是我们的障碍所在
我们把它们放在那里
因为通常我们在
你知道吗
缩小规模的操作
然后我们在那里有栅栏来做我们的
你知道我们的十字架
Q E同步
这将有助于确保我们的个人提交实际上执行
当他们需要的时候
所以如果你这样做
你知道这很适合很多硬件
对，因为你知道你是普通的AMD和英伟达硬件通常会有
你知道至少有一个
比如图形前端，通常是多个计算前端
所以像这样的设置，你提交到一个计算队列
是利用硬件的好方法
你只需要记住一件事
如果你要这么做
你的目标是尝试
就像你知道的提高利用率
你知道通过额外的计算提交来使用你的着色器核心
完全有可能您知道您的不同提交最终将并发运行
但这根本不是一个有保证的保证
因为有所有的复杂性
你知道的
我提到过
你们之间有一个完整的操作系统时间表
以及您的提交和实际硬件
所以这真的取决于这一切是如何解决的
您知道时间表将决定同时运行您的命令
在GPU中，驱动程序必须实际暴露
你知道的
运行命令的调度程序的引擎
所以有点像
你知道吗
CPU上的线程
对呀
你想做多少线程就做多少线程
但实际上并不能保证
它们将在不同的核心上同时运行
完全有可能
只有一个核心，线程只是序列化的
你可以在Gpus上做同样的事情
所以你必须用
通常用特殊的工具
所以你知道用调度器和引擎来实现这一切
所有直接12真的就像在引擎盖下虚拟化你的线索
所以重要的是要记住你知道
命令队列对象不是到硬件队列的直接映射
你知道它更多的是插入操作系统调度程序
所以你知道
因为硬件在那里，它可能只有
你知道它可能有很多计算队列
或者它可能有
你知道没有计算队列
只有一个队列可以正确地完成所有事情
所以操作系统和调度器的工作
它会在DirectX 12中为您解决这个问题
这有点酷
所以如果你提交了很多不同队列的命令列表
操作系统会想出办法让它工作
它可以通过将您的提交扁平化到不同的队列来做到这一点
并将它们全部提交到一个硬件队列中
它可以做到这一点，因为你知道你的栅栏只在两者之间
命令缓冲区提交
而不是在他们里面
而且
因为您的栅栏为调度程序提供了依赖项的全局可见性
这样调度人员就可以把一切都弄清楚
甚至可以为你做像技术死锁这样的事情
但这也使围栏成为一种重量级的操作
从CPU的角度来看
因为它们实际上是在输入操作系统
所以你得小心不要用太多
如果你想知道到底发生了什么
你应该经常检查GPU视图是一个好工具
它可以向你展示你是如何实际的CPU和GPU工作是如何执行的
选择窗口作为时间捕获
它可以向你展示事情在GPU上是如何相关的
到您的提交点在CPU中的位置
Radion图形探查器有另一个类似的好视图
里面也有线的痕迹
这样我就可以向你展示关于如何
当你的工作在GPU上实际执行时
所以你应该经常检查看看事情进展如何
以及它们是如何堆积的
然后也要记住
火神星的线索实际上和这个有点不同
你知道吗，我一直在谈论X12
但是火神星的线索并不是以同样的方式虚拟化的
它们有一点不同的界面
所以你在瓦肯要做的是
您实际上必须在运行时查询设备上有哪些可用的提示
它会说嘿
该设备有一个图形队列和八个计算队列
然后你必须基本上当你创建你的命令线索提交
你
必须绑定到设备上可用并公开的插槽
所以因为这个显式绑定
你必须真正改变你分手和提交东西的方式
所以你知道如果你打算做
哦
我想做的计算队列提交
然后事实证明硬件没有
该设备不会向您公开任何计算机队列
你得想办法把自己压扁
而直接x12它会为你做的
它会找到办法做到这一点
嗯
但不管怎样，还是喜欢暴露的东西
而火神装置仍然不是
你知道不能保证
你知道用硬件队列一对一
所以你不应该假设是这样
所以是的
所以总的来说，就像你知道的，就像我说的，你知道这个技术
我们称之为异步计算
基本上就是
你要试着利用额外的计算前端
在Gpus上安排一些计算工作，希望可以并行
你知道
填写您的
你知道你的主要图形提交或其他计算提交
所以如果你要尝试这样做来提高你的帧时间
你基本上你知道
你要试着填满这个空闲的着色器核心
所以真的
这将是最好的工作
如果你能找出你的核心在哪里闲置并填写它们
就像我们在那个例子中所做的那样
我们早些时候在MJP
四千
是同样的概念
只是更复杂
你知道还有很多细节
但这有点粗糙
你知道吗
它的基础
所以说
为了做到这一点
您还希望标识独立的命令流
因为这将是你的机会
提交
就像在不同的线索上一样
所以你知道
如果你基本上我们要找
就像更长的命令流
彼此没有依赖
但它们可能在您的单个命令流中具有依赖关系
就像你知道的
就像我之前展示的你的绽放和景深
我们就像是完美的例子
当然你知道这会是最好的
当你有很多重要的着色器核心
所以你应该寻找这些机会
就像我已经提到的，只有深度效果图
试图
你知道的
闲置着色器核心
或者如果你的一个队列上有很多障碍
那将是你可以
希望像潜入一些泥瓦匠计算
你知道利用空闲着色器核心好的
所以我简单回顾一下，以确保我把重要的观点带回家
嗯第一
所以你发布的GPU屏障
他们基本上会确保你的数据可见性
这就是他们的全部
这就是为什么你要
你知道的
这就是为什么你必须做他们
所以你知道他们可能会涉及某种
你知道GPU线程同步
你知道的
尤其是如果你在中间有一个屏障
就像两个调度或两个抽签电话
可能取决于硬件
它们可能涉及缓存刷新器和无效
我也是
所以你要小心
然后他们也依赖其他
你知道硬件特定的东西
它们可能涉及某种数据转换或布局更改
这通常是某种形式的减压操作
所以这也会使东西比平时更贵
而且真的
当你在D 3 D 12中提交你的障碍时
和沃尔克
你真的是在描述你的访问吗？
您的资源可见性和依赖关系
所以真的如果你想做
你知道的
试着优化你的障碍，尽可能地减少它们
那么您应该仔细考虑您在整个框架中的依赖关系
它可以帮助你把它形象化就像把它们画出来一样
然后你就可以看到你的大同步点在哪里
也可以做一些你喜欢的事情
使用框架图结构自动为您确定依赖关系
你知道类似于3D11在做什么
但希望如果您在自己的代码中这样做
你可以做得更快
然后你可以发出正确和最优的屏障
我想开车回家的另一个要点是
全球定位系统并没有什么不同
至少与典型的多核CPU编程相比
你可以把你的命令处理器想象成一个硬件任务调度器
对呀
这只是一种编排工作
这将被安排在着色器核心上运行
你知道的
而不是你的着色器核心基本上取代了你的工人
线程或核心
CPU任务调度器上的内容
然后你知道你真的有一些同样的问题
当你在做多核CPU编程时
你知道你在飞行中仍然有类似的并行操作
你必须确保通过设置正确的障碍来避免比赛条件
你仍然可以有一些一致性和内存
您必须处理的订购问题
这些还需要在代码中设置手动障碍
第三点是你知道总的来说
有障碍会导致
你知道的
GPU上的空闲内核
这让你的GPU很难过
所以你知道你真的想让线程怪物吃饱
它很饿
它有很多核心，所以你想
你知道的
最大限度地减少你的障碍
因为任何一种障碍都会导致
像一个重物或一个摊位
这会降低你的利用率
所以自然地让你小心地使用屏障会导致更高的利用率
希望更高的三次推杆和更低的帧数
我总是注意很长的线程
尤其是如果他们不多
这些家伙可能会导致
你知道的
你框架中的自然点
你在长线程上同步
在GPU中没有太多其他的事情发生
你知道这不是在做一个
这不是对大型并联机器的最佳利用
然后呢
当然啦
就像每个人都说过一百遍的那样
但总是批量处理你的障碍
因为刷新一次缓存总是要花很多钱
很多
比连续冲多次好多了
如果你想冒险尝试使用多个队列
你知道的
记住你知道做多个线索
划界案
你知道你可能会得到
你知道它们可能会并行执行
它可能会提高你的利用率
但这取决于很多因素
所以你应该经常检查你的工具，看看发生了什么
并确保你真的从中受益
然后就是
当然，它不会神奇地增加你的核心数量
所以如果你有你已经被瓶颈的地方
GP着色器的自然资源
核心或其内存带宽
这不会因为提交多个键而增加
你知道这可能会让事情变得更糟
取决于不同队列上发生的工作类型
然后你应该一直
你知道的
正在寻找您的独立命令流
纠正没有依赖项的命令组
在另一组命令上
这将是您以单独密钥提交它们的最佳案例
然后你也要小心
你知道你不想发疯
有栅栏的三十二
每一个围栏都很重量级
从CPU和GPU的角度来看
所以你想
你知道要小心平衡
我的演讲到此结束
我只是
你知道的
我想在他的演讲中向顾问们大喊一声
如你所知
史蒂夫·托维·雷索默菲尔德
他帮我加入了谈话
nvidia的nick aberos和andrea torino
然后收音机里的每个人都看着我跑过
给了我很多宝贵的反馈
如果你想联系我的工作和个人电子邮件都在上面
还有我的推特
嗯
也是我博客的链接
如果你还没看过的话
这里有一系列的博客文章
就在这上面
就像同一主题
它只是去了更多的细节
所以请随意阅读
也是我的GitHub的链接
在那里我得到了各种各样的开源项目
你可以退房
所以在这一点上
如果有人有任何问题
请随意走到麦克风前
我们有机会操纵线索的优先级吗
对不起
请你再说一遍好吗？
我们是否操纵线索的优先级
优先事项优先事项
哦优先队列
哦嗯
我不这么认为
没有一个API实际上公开了为Q设置优先级的能力
嗯
他们实际上有一个在D三D十二
据我所知
现在在D3 D12上有正常的高优先级
我相信它只影响操作系统中的实际调度程序
所以它实际上并不
我不相信目前的GPU和驱动程序真的用这些信息做任何事情
但它实际上只有在至少以我的经验来看
当你的硬件没有多个线索时
操作系统正在把它们压扁
所以说
如果您有图形提交和异步计算提交
所以操作系统基本上会做一个和另一个
然后如果你标记优先级
基本上操作系统会把它翻过来
我们将一个先于另一个提交
当它这样做的时候
我还没有真正看到
它对AMD或英伟达硬件有任何影响
支持异步计算
或者类似的东西
但我不能百分百肯定这是真的还是假的
所以我不想完全相信我的话
一切都好
所有的权利
然后呢
非常感谢
谢谢你能来